an ukrainischen zivilisten in butter und
die sich daraus ergebenden konsequenzen
ich gebe das wort für bündnis 90 die
grünen der kollegin britta haßelmann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
bilder und nachrichten aus butter nun
zwei tagen erreichen sind schrecklich
sie sind grausam die bilder von feige
ermordeten menschen von massengräbern
die verzweiflung und tränen von müttern
und vätern und kindern haben uns alle
ins mark getroffen
es sind menschen wie sie und ich die bis
vor ein paar wochen noch ein ganz
normales leben frei und selbstbestimmt
mitten in europa geführt haben ich
möchte an dieser stelle dem präsidenten
zielinski und einen angehörigen
stellvertretend für so viele menschen in
der ukraine
mein tiefes mitgefühl aussprechen
auch hier
meine damen und herren fast unfassbare
trauer auch hier herrscht unfassbare hut
und auch wenn der kreml versucht durch
desinformation
lügen und propaganda
unbelegte zweifel zu säen und seiner
anhänger selbst hier in deutschland
versuchen diese zweifel und
desinformation und propaganda zu
verbreiten
eins ist doch klar hinter diesen
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
steht putin und steht seine armee die
dokumentation der kriegsverbrechen und
die aufarbeitung müssen jetzt beginnen
putin und seine gefolgsleute werden sich
dafür vor dem internationalen
strafgericht verantworten müssen
meine damen und herren
die worte die zerstörung und die gold
hatten zeitnah furchtbarste weise mit
welcher unfassbaren brutalität
der russische präsident seinen krieg
gegen die ukrainische zivilbevölkerung
führt die kriegsverbrechen der
russischen armee können wir nicht
unbeantwortet lassen wir müssen
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern mit g7 im transatlantischen
bündnis
alles was möglich ist tun diese
unmenschliche brutalität ein zu dem der
druck auf putin und sein system auf die
die ihn stützen muss dringend erhöht
werden ich hoffe darüber besteht konsens
zwischen den demokratinnen und
demokraten dieses hauses es kommt jetzt
auf ein gemeinsames entschlossen des
europäisches und internationales
vorgehen an schärfere sanktionen werden
wir jetzt in diesen tagen in diesen
stunden in einem fünf sanktionspaket in
der europäischen kommission in der
europäischen gemeinschaft beschließen um
den druck auf putins machtapparat auf
sein system
weiter zu erhöhen dazu gehören
einfuhrverbote für kohle dazu gehören
transaktions verbote gegen wichtige
weitere russische banken ein weiteres
einfrieren von vermögenswerten und
einiges mehr was die europäischen
staaten gemeldet haben und was notwendig
ist die sanktionen wirklich zu
verschärfen und einfach noch mehr druck
über dieses sanktionsregime auszulösen
dieses paket wird auch das fundament
sein
für einen komplettausstieg aus der
abhängigkeit von russlands fossiler
energie und damit dass putin regime auch
klar plan noch ja treffen als es das mit
dem bisherigen sanktions paketen den 1
bis 4 schon tut härtere sanktionen und
der weg raus aus den fossilen energien
russlands werden von den europäerinnen
und europäern gemeinsam gegangen und
zwar so schnell wie möglich und das ist
die wichtige nachricht wir müssen an
dieser stelle gemeinsam handeln
entschlossen hier und jetzt unser ziel
muss es sein frust land wirtschaftlich
und finanziell abzukoppeln oder anderen
ländern zu schaden gerade den ärmeren
ländern das muss uns gelingen diese
klare internationale und europäische
haltung diese gemeinsame antwort das ist
das worauf es jetzt ankommt meine damen
und herren und dazu gehören auch die
waffenlieferungen und dazu gehört auch
die frage alles was machbar ist im
europäischen kontext zu diskutieren und
dies auch gemeinsam jetzt auf den weg zu
bringen im hinblick auf
waffenlieferungen und das sage ich für
meine fraktion genauso überzeugt wie
andere hier im haus und wie wir in der
europäischen gemeinsam gemeinschaft
vermutlich zusammen meine damen und
herren putin diesen krieg gegen die
ukraine und gegen diese verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit sofort stoppen und
ich bin mir sicher wir werden gemeinsam
mit unseren partnern in europa in
transatlantischen bündnis mit der
verschärfung der sanktionen mit der
unterstützung liegen recht auf
selbstverteidigung durch
waffenlieferungen und humanitäre hilfe
alles was machbar ist tun um diese diese
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit zu
stoppen vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion gebe ich jetzt
mit den kollegen doktrin wade
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich kann dich der kollegin bosselmann
noch vollkommen
anschließen das ist nicht nur ein
völkerrechtswidriger krieg das ist ein
krieg der unter verletzung der grund
normen der humanität und verletzung der
grund normen der genfer
konvention geführt wird der keine
rücksicht mehr nimmt auf schwache
menschen auch kinder frauen auf
schwangere auf altem das ist ein
krieg der auf apathische art und weise
geführt wird und in der tat ich schließe
mich ihre aufforderung an und bin für
meine fraktion gerne bereit das zu
erklären hier müssen wir zusammenstehen
und gemeinsam auf der richtigen seite
stehen und gemeinsam auf der seite der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer stehen mal
gesagt wir hatten damen und herren
sie will aber einräumen frau kollegin
dass ich mir so klare worte wie sie von
ihm gehört habe die ich sie auch von
frau strack-zimmermann lese von annalena
baerbock auch weitgehend höre auch vom
bundeskanzler gewünscht hätte ja ich
höre nicht damit auf weil er wohin die
fresken in einer fragestunde fragen
ausgewichen ist unklar geblieben ist und
sich zu dieser frage nicht geäußert
gegen jede woche auch die gelegenheit
hätte klar zu sagen wofür steht meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren so ein
krieg kann
prinzipiell drei auswege haben kann die
eine seite gewinnen das kann die andere
seite gewinnen und es kann ein
verständigungsmittel geben nachdem wir
das letztere in dieser
auseinandersetzung glaube ich nicht
erwarten können müssen wir uns
entscheiden auf welcher seite wir mit
welchen mitteln stehen wollen und da
kann ich nur sagen in dieser situation
wir wollten nie wir wollen nicht an dem
krieg formel teilnehmen aber in dieser
situation muss deutschland muss die
freie welt wirklich aber auch alles tun
dass putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
denn das würde
das würde das würde
das wäre eine das würde eine grosse
niederlage für uns alle sein das wäre
eine niederlage für deutschland das wäre
eine niederlage für menschenrechte das
wäre eine niederlage für die europäische
union es wäre im übrigen für alle
staaten auf der welt die das unterstützt
haben auch in den vereinten nationen an
die niederlage es wäre eine niederlage
für den präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten von amerika und wir alle oder
für viele von uns die allermeisten von
uns nicht sagen weil die demokratische
mitte in jedem fall wünscht sich ja kaum
dass er trump wieder zum präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten von amerika gewählt
wird das heißt die der schluss muss doch
sein dass wir jetzt in dieser situation
wirklich alles tun was in unseren
möglichkeiten steht in der tat unterhalb
einer formellen beteiligung der nato und
der bundeswehr dass dieser krieg von den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gewonnen wird
dass sie sich erfolgreich verteidigen
können meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und da muss ich sagen finde ich
an der stelle weil sie es nicht herne
und der bundeskanzler ihrer antwort von
vorhin da musste man ja bei der dritten
nachfrage versuchen herauszulesen was
sagen sie denn nun zum thema schwere
waffen es ist eine pin sind man mag es
nicht schön finden aber es ist eine
militärische binnensee dass in dieser
situation des krieges die ukraine
renault kreiner wenn sie sich
erfolgreich verteidigen sollen schweres
gerät brauchen gepanzerte waffen
bergepanzer brücken lege panzer
vielleicht sogar kampfbahn zahlen
vielleicht sogar artillerie geschosse
die brauchen sie nun mal um bestehen zu
können
und da muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
antwort heute hier ist ja da sollte
deutschland nicht vorpreschen da sollten
wir nicht die ersten sein die das machen
dann ist das aus meiner sicht eine
unzureichende antwort dann wird
deutschland seiner verantwortung für die
agrar für die ukraine in dieser
historischen situation schlicht nicht
recht meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das muss man sagen ja ich will
ihnen das ganz offen sagen ich habe das
von der frage gesagt ich kenne
geschäftsführer von rüstungsunternehmen
die sagen mir sie haben jede woche
wieder bei einem referatsleiter im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium zu tun die
in frage gestellt die der
bundeskanzlerin auch angedeutet hat
können die ukraine denn überhaupt mit
den waffen umgehen wo wollt ihr die
übergeben können die ukraine renault
ukraine das überhaupt bezahlen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wenn wir
auf diesem bürokratischen niveau am ende
die ganze geschichte kaputt machen
wollen dann sagen sie es bitte ehrlich
ich bin der meinung wir stehen auf der
seite der ukraine und müssen das dann
auch leisten
und dazu gehört die frage der
energieversorgung die natürlich keine
kleine frage ist und das will ich auch
nicht abschließend hier sagen dass ich
alles beurteilen kann nur wenn robert
habeck sagt also wenn wir das abschalten
ist es eine katastrophe
aber wenn putin das macht dann ist es
beherrschbar ist mindestens mal ein
offenkundiger logischer widerspruch und
deswegen sage ich diese bundesregierung
was aus der unentschiedenheit
herauskommen sie muss ich klar bekennen
sie muss eine führungsrolle unternehmen
sie muss wo sie wissen wo sie steht in
dieser situation und erst recht nach
butscher an der seite der ukraine an der
seite der mitmenschlichkeit herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
für die bundesregierung greift christine
lambrecht das wort
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die bilder die uns aus der
ukraine erreichen sie sind schrecklich
ist sie zeigen wo tals der gräueltaten
an zivilisten begangen werden und
unsere gedanken sind bei den opfern und
ihren angehörigen
wenn wir ehrlich sind dann ist dieser
angriffskrieg dieser brutale
angriffskrieg schon ein verbrechen aber
das was wir da gesehen haben was wir da
sehen müssen das ist eine
entmenschlichung die alle grenzen
überschritten hat und
was da ist
putin nimmt diese grauenvollen diese
grausamen taten in kauf aber es wäre zu
kurz gesprungen wenn wir das alles nur
auf putin reduzieren würden es sind
nämlich nicht nur seine taten sondern
jeder kommandant der so etwas befehligt
jeder soldat der so eine tat ausführt
oder geschehen lässt der macht sich
mindestens genauso schuldig meine damen
und
alle müssen sich fragen lassen ist das
dass russland für das ihr die uniform
trägt für das wir stehen volt ist das
dass russland für das ihr kämpft und die
internationale gemeinschaft muss klar
antworten jede tat muss schonungslos
verfolgt werden und es muss alles dafür
getan werden alles dass wirklich jeder
einzelne kriegsverbrecher auch seine
entsprechende harte strafe bekommen
aber wir sehen in den straßen von
butscher mehr als nur leichen in deren
straßen wir sehen im grellen licht die
grausamkeit des system putins es ist ein
system dem alle mittel recht sind um
seine interessen durchzusetzen ein
system das nationalistischen großmacht
zwar alles unterordnet dass keine
grenzen kennt und keine hemmung ein
system das recht und menschlichkeit mit
füßen tritt und deswegen darf dieses
system nicht gewinnen es darf sich nicht
durchsetzen wer so handelt wie putin dem
ist es egal ob die leichen auf den
strassen von butter oder leichen auf den
strassen von tiflis vilnius oder berlin
sind und daher müssen wir die ukraine in
ihrem kampf gegen das system putin
stützen unterstützen wo wir nur können
und dabei geht es nicht darum und dabei
geht es nicht darum schlagzeilen zu
produzieren oder sich moralisch zu
erleichtern nein es geht darum ganz
konkret zu helfen ganz konkret zu
unterstützen
denn wir können diesen krieg so sehr
schmerzt nicht mit einem schlag beenden
und aber wir können wir können die
russische fähigkeit zur kriegsführung
sprechen ja bereits beispiellos harte
sanktionen erlassen sanktionen die
russland an das land an den rand eines
staatsbankrotts gebracht haben und die
zunehmend ihre volle wirkung entfalten
und jetzt werden wir noch einmal
entschlossen und gezielt nachlegen und
dabei dann auch den import von
energieträgern im blick haben ganz
aktuell das vorgeschlagene importverbot
für russische kohle ist dabei ein ganz
wichtiger baustein
meine damen und herren wir haben die
ukraine bereits in großem umfang auch
mit waffen beliefert unterstützt und wir
arbeiten jeden tag mit hochdruck daran
weitere
waffen liefern zu können
und dafür sind wir im ständigen
austausch mit der ukrainischen regierung
mit unseren alliierten und partnern und
auch mit der rüstungsindustrie
wenn wir über die art und zahl der
gelieferten waffen aber nicht öffentlich
reden dann hat das einen guten grund die
ukraine hat ausdrücklich darum gebeten
und wir halten uns daran es geht aus
militärischer sicht nämlich darum dass
russland im unklaren über die typen und
mängeln der gelieferten waffen ist und
sich nicht darauf einstellen kann der
feind hört nämlich mit und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir handeln aber
nicht darüber reden weil das würde das
ziel gefährden nämlich die ukraine zu
unterstützen
und wollen dass es kein keine
bürokratische hürde in diesem
zusammenhang ist eines ganz wichtig die
nato und deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur kriegspartei zu
werden denn das ist für ganz ganz viele
menschen eine große sorge momentan wie
geht das weiter wie wirkt sich das aus
was bedeutet das auch für uns wie
entwickelt sich diese spirale das kann
man nicht einfach als bürokratische
hürde abtun nein dieser verantwortung
müssen wir nachkommen und da sind wir
uns mit unseren verbündeten in der nato
mit unseren partnern in der europäischen
union sehr sehr einig das wird diese
grenze nicht überschreiten wollen und
auch nicht überschreiten werden wir
müssen verhindern dass es einen
flächenbrand in europa in europa gibt
mit allen sich daraus ergebenden
schrecklichen konsequenzen
man hat ja das system putin darf nicht
gewinnen darf sich nicht durchsetzen
denn sonst können wir uns alle nicht
mehr sicher seien und daher müssen wir
auch in deutschland lernen sehr viel
wehrhafter zu sein sehr viel wehrhaft da
zu sein und dieser gedanke steht hinter
der sicherheitspolitischen zeitenwende
die der bundeskanzler verkündet hat
dieser gedanke steht hinter dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr wenn wir heute in
unsere streitkräfte investieren dann
geht es nämlich darum unsere werte von
recht und menschlichkeit gegen das
system putin zu verteidigen da geht es
darum uns und unsere verbündeten gegen
militärische erpressung und gewalt
abzusichern vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion spricht der kollege
jürgen braun
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin auf liebe kollegen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
mutter war eine ruhige kleinstadt
unmittelbar vor den toren kehre erst mit
einem großen see und viel grün das käfer
großbürgertum der vorrevolutionären zeit
vor dorthin in die sommerfrische wie man
damals hierzulande gesagt hätte nichts
erinnert jetzt mehr an diese
vergangenheit denn bis vor wenigen tagen
sollten leichen die straßen butchers wie
während des holodomor des
kommunistischen völkermords an den
ukrainern
natürlich kann in jedem krieg nicht nur
der aggressor kriegsverbrechen begehen
sondern ebenso der verteidiger wir als
fdp fordern eine zweistufige
untersuchung zunächst
möglichst schnell durch die drei
experten die der uno menschenrechtsrat
erst letzte woche für die ukraine
benannt hat der norwegische chef
ermittler dieser kommission hat schon
dass ruanda tribunal geleitet und als
zweite stufe falls die kommission zu
entsprechenden ergebnissen gelangt ein
kriegsverbrechertribunal wie zum
ehemaligen jugoslawien dass eine
lückenlose aufklärung ohne ansehen der
kriegspartei leistet
was ist aber jetzt schon gibt
satellitenaufnahmen und zeugenberichte
tatjana wladimirowna eine alte frau aus
butscher erzählt wie ein mann getötet
wurde drei soldaten darunter ein
tschetschene stürmten ihre wohnung
misshandelten und
verschleppten ihn
hier hatte der tschetschene mit schlägen
gedroht falls sie sich widersetzte sie
suchte ihren mann anschließend tagelang
bei der russischen armee gab man ihr
keine auskunft eine freundin sagt hier
schließlich es seien leichen im keller
eines nachbarhauses gefunden worden
tatiana erkannte ihren mann nur an den
turnschuhen so entstellt war die leiche
und begraben muss diese sie ihn
gemeinsam mit freunden denn die
russischen truppen kümmerten sich nicht
einmal darum die leichen zu verscharren
die betrachtung prima phase also der
erste anschein spricht führt die klare
täterschaft einer bestimmten seite und
sollte sich das als wahr erweisen dann
muss dieses grausame handeln
konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
befragt nach dem hintergrund solcher
verbrechen erklärte der osteuropa
historiker jörg barofsky zitat die
soldaten der russischen armee werden
mangelhaft versorgt leiden hunger und
frieren sie werden von ihren offizieren
tyrannisiert menschen die solche
behandlung ausgesetzt sind geraten außer
sich sobald sich ihnen eine gelegenheit
bietet andere menschen genauso zu
behandeln
überzeugt davon am 31 märz suchen sich
die russischen streitkräfte zurück am
ersten april nahm die ukrainische armee
die stadt ein das erste video ausputzer
noch weitgehend unbeachtet von den
westlichen medien ist am selben tag
aufgetaucht und amerikanischen
satelliten aufnahmen zeigen inzwischen
dass die leichen tage lang dort lagen
trotzdem wäre dem russischen
staatsfernsehen behauptet alles sei
arrangiert leichen gar keine leichen die
ersten aufnahmen erst tage nach der
rückeroberung
aufgetaucht und die russische propaganda
wird auch vom deutschen staat funk
genährt der bundes faktencheck georg
reste der noch vor kurzem putin als
realpolitiker gelobt hat erklärt uns
jetzt die ukraine hätten journalisten
keinen zugang zu bewerten dabei hatte
die ard über wochen gar keinen eigenen
reporter in kiew trotz zwangsgebühren in
milliarden höhe
plötzlich entdeckt auch die nun
oppositionelle cdu ihren
widerstandsgeist ihre vorsitzende angela
merkel hat auch erst dafür gesorgt dass
deutschland derart abhängig von
russischem gas wurde und zwar mit ihrem
kopflosen links grünen atomausstieg
und es ist auch merkels erbe wenn
bundeskanzler scholz der teilweisen
trifft abschaltung russlands erst als
letzter eu regierungschefs zustimmen so
war nach viktor orban den sie liebe
kollegen von der union jahrelang als
putin freund beschimpft haben
exemplarisch für den umgang unserer
regierung mit dem ukraine krieg steht
eine szene aus dem
menschenrechtsausschuss die ich vor zwei
wochen wird er erlebt habe die kollegin
engelhardt von der spd klagte bei einer
unterrichtung dass die ukraine transfer
nicht als frauen sondern als männer
betrachtet und für sie der wehrdienst
gelte und die genossen fragte erster
ernsthaft ob sich die bundesregierung
dafür einsetzen dass die ukraine auf
trans frauen als frauen anerkennen werde
das ist leider kein witz was die kleine
jetzt braucht sind keine belehrung in
sachen gander das ist sogar das letzte
was sie jetzt braucht was die ukraine
braucht das ist ein starkes wehrhaftes
europa der vaterländer vielen dank
[Applaus]
wien die österreicher hat das wort für
die fdp fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die grauenvollen bilder die uns seit dem
vergangenen wochenende ausrutscher
erreichen sind unerträglich
mit dem rückzug der russischen truppen
aus dem großraum hier wird das ausmaß
der zerstörung und der barbarei immer
deutlicher vor den augen der ganzen welt
bricht putins russland das völkerrecht
mit einer brutalität die ihresgleichen
sucht
bis vor einer woche hatte ich den namen
butscher noch nie gehört bis vor einer
woche bis vor einer woche wusste ich
nicht einmal wo dieser ort auf der
landkarte liegt
ich bin mir aber sicher dass künftige
generation ob in der ukraine in
deutschland oder in ganz europa wissen
werden was in botschaft passiert ist und
wofür dieser ort steht butscher steht
für unfassbar viel leid gewalt und
grauenhafte verbrechen
satellitenbildern zufolge liegen dort
die toten männer frauen und kinder seien
wochen auf den straßen teilweise
gefesselt geknebelt und
mit spuren von vergewaltigungen
ohnmacht angst hilflosigkeit
noch immer habe ich das gesicht von
präsident alan ski vor augen der mit
ausländischen journalisten durch butter
geht damit diese der welt zeigen können
welche grausamen massaker an
unschuldigen zivilisten begangen wurden
sein gesichtsausdruck
spiegelt all jene gefühle wider die so
viele ukrainische mütter väter und
angehörige in diesen tagen schmerzhaft
durchleben
die toten von butscher
sie alle hatten freunde und verwandte
sie alle waren menschen mit träumen und
sorgen für das leben sie alle hatten
individuellen biografien und sie alle
waren einzigartig
ich weiß nicht was wir noch viel bilder
zu sehen bekommen werden aber ich
befürchte dass die grausamen bilder aus
butter nur die spitze des eisberges sind
meine damen und herren in den letzten
tagen ist viel über die deutsche außen-
und sicherheitspolitik gesprochen worden
sehr oft habe ich in den letzten tagen
gehört dass wir alle naiv gegenüber
russland gewesen sind und putin falsch
eingeschätzt haben diese fehler dürfen
sich nicht wiederholen und gerade jetzt
in dieser situation dürfen wir erst
recht nicht naiv sein der westen
der westen hat nach dem georgien krieg
nicht entschlossen gegenüber putin
reagiert der westen hat nicht
geschlossen auf die krim aktion reagiert
der westen hat sich im wesentlichen
weggedreht als russland in syrien ganze
städte und dörfer ausradiert hat wir
müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
solange dieses regime existiert meine
damen und herren wird es keine
sicherheit in europa geben
dürfen
künftige künftige generationen werden
uns die frage stellen egal ob regierung
oder opposition
werden uns die frage stellen wie wir uns
in diesen schicksalsstunden europas
verhalten haben wir sind es nicht nur
den opfern dieses krieges schuldig wir
sind es uns auch selbst schuldig jede
form der wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
mit diesem regime ist eine schande und
muss schnellstmöglich beendet werden
meine damen und herren
deutschland und europa zeigen sich
dieser dunkle stunde der europäischen
geschichte solidarisch mit der ukraine
nicht nur mit schönen worten auch mit
taten weitere taten und handlungen
müssen folgen eine breit gefächerte
unterstützung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte ist von äußerster
wichtigkeit
jetzt ist die zeit gekommen russland
klar zu machen dass die beziehungen zum
westen endgültig zu bruch gegangen ist
solange putin die macht im kreml innehat
die welt wird die gräueltaten von
butscher niemals vergessen wir werden
und müssen alles dafür dass die dass die
verantwortlichen für diese verbrechen
zur rechenschaft gezogen werden meine
damen und herren putin hat versucht mit
seinen brutalen angriffskrieg die
ukraine zu vernichten und den westen zu
spalten das ist ihm nicht gelungen meine
damen und herren und das wird ihm auch
nicht gelingen
wir stehen fest an der seite aller
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
die diesen schweren tagen um ihre
freiheit und ihr leben kämpfen salvá
ukraine
[Applaus]